you know there's nothing worse than
having someone give you the wrong
diagnosis they'll say
you have a slow metabolism right because
you can't lose weight fast
so when you're given this false
diagnosis
then you're very susceptible to doing
the wrong thing because then you're
going to be focused on trying to find
some thing to boost your metabolism well
that doesn't work in reality the problem
is not a slow
metabolism let me explain so what is
metabolism you have all these chemical
reactions going in your body whether
you're breaking down food into energy or
building things back up into body tissue
like repairing things like maintaining
temperature and eliminating waste all
that is part of metabolism some people
tell you to create a negative caloric
condition
where you're consuming less calories
than you're eating okay eat less and
then you need to exercise more and then
after about six months of doing this you
haven't really lost a pound they
basically heat up these calories and
burn them okay in a lab to determine
how much energy is in a carbohydrate fat
and protein but in the body in a
biological system
things work completely different you
have a lot more complexities going on
number one you have hormones and that's
really the missing factor is the hormone
influence over
your specific
calories
so hormones are basically the
communications in your body and the very
important hormone that relates to
whether you burn fat or store fat is
insulin so the insulin message is store
fat if insulin goes up you store fat if
insulin goes down it's a different
message it's burn fat
so in reality if insulin is too high
that is going to mimic a slow metabolism
because as soon as you lower it you
start to burn fat but if that hormone is
just a little too high
not only will you not be able to burn
fat but the body's going to enhance the
storage of calories into fat you see
this video is all about
focusing in on the real problem so then
you can have an actual solution to fix
it if we know what triggers insulin and
how to inhibit it then you will know how
to lose weight and you're about to find
out why that is so different than
thinking you have a slow metabolism and
you need to speed up your metabolism it
just actually will make things worse
whether you're taking like caffeine or
energy boosters or certain herbs that
stimulate your metabolism they end up
burning out your metabolism so before i
get into the triggers let me just
explain what happens
when this hormone insulin goes up you're
going to experience several symptoms
okay you're gonna find that you're
hungry more often you're gonna crave
carbohydrates you're gonna have frequent
urination especially at night
you're gonna have a tendency to have
more belly fat you're gonna have fatigue
you're gonna have cognitive issues
because you're going to have brain fog
you're not going to be able to focus as
well
your mood is going to be affected you
might feel more grouchy you might have
more anxiety and you're definitely going
to have more liver fat and that's really
what's creating a spill off into your
abdominal area where you have belly fat
you're also going to notice that your
set point okay that weight
that you just can't get below is going
to be really
stuck if not raised
so
in other words let's say you you do all
these different methods of trying to
lose weight and you just can't seem to
get below 160 or 155 you're just stuck
there
well that is called a set point and
insulin is really behind the set point
the inability
to continue to lose weight and there's
one more really interesting symptom
related to this if your insulin is too
high
you will start or your liver will start
making extra sugar
not from sugar from your diet but from
other things like your own fat and
protein that's called gluconeogenesis
gluco meaning sugar neo meaning new
genesis meaning the creation of and
you're making new sugars because of a
very interesting situation where your
insulin has been chronically high for so
long
you develop this other condition called
insulin resistance
which means your body has to compensate
and make more insulin to create the same
effect so you have certain parts of your
body where you're expressing symptoms of
too much insulin yet other parts of your
body where you're experiencing too
little insulin and one common thing that
you see especially with diabetics that
have insulin resistance which they
always do
is this extra production of sugar from
your liver and you usually see it when a
person comes off the sugar
and then they
have high sugars especially in the
morning and they're like where this
coming from well it's coming from this
insulin resistance situation
all right so now let's talk about two
different things we'll talk about what
triggers insulin and what inhibits
insulin if you understand both sides of
the coin then you
personally can control your own weight
okay so
what triggers insulin well it's carbs
okay carbs and definitely sugar okay
what inhibits insulin
low carbs that's the ketogenic diet all
right another big trigger to insulin is
frequent eating okay like snacking and
grazing there's nothing
more powerful to trigger insulin and
stop you losing weight then the small
snacks through the day because you're
constantly triggering insulin all day
long and it's this chronic sustained
high insulin that puts you in a
situation where you're just not going to
lose weight no matter what so that means
one of the things that inhibit insulin
is fasting okay intermittent fasting
this is why we recommend keto
intermittent fasting and that is so
powerful to address
what you think might be a slow
metabolism in reality it's just an
insulin problem another thing that will
trigger insulin is excessive amounts of
protein especially if it's low
fat or no fat protein as in
whey protein powder that on the insulin
index is pretty darn
high now of course that doesn't compare
to eating sugar but it's still a factor
that could be a problem all right now on
the inhibiting side okay what will keep
insulin low
and
make insulin more
sensitive and less resistance is
exercise specifically resistance
training okay working your whole body at
a certain volume and in certain uh
intensity
uh that's very very beneficial for
insulin resistance
and there's two other things
that will not trigger insulin okay one
is fiber
natural fiber from things like
vegetables now i'm not talking about the
fake fibers
like fiber yum for example which is a
synthetic fiber which will definitely
increase
your insulin i'm talking about the
natural fiber from vegetables not the
fiber from grains because grains
comes with too many carbs but actual
really healthy type natural fiber
and then we have
fat okay
fat apparently does not trigger insulin
and this is very
surprising to people because they've
been taught that you need to avoid fat
with a slow metabolism well guess what
they didn't really have a slow
metabolism in the first place they had
too much insulin and fat is one of the
things that doesn't trigger insulin
interesting now as far as eating fat
goes um as long as you keep your carbs
low you're going to be totally fine
that's why the ketogenic diet has is a
good percentage of fat because we keep
our carbs really really low and we keep
moderate amount of protein all right
another trigger
for this insulin
is stress okay when the stress goes up
the cortisol goes up
another name for cortisol is
glucocorticoids
because it's a hormone that also
controls glucose to a certain degree and
it will turn
your proteins even your body tissue
into glucose one of the side effects of
high levels of sustained cortisol output
is diabetes because you're changing the
protein into glucose and it's not coming
from the dietary sugars it's coming from
stress so stress can make you fat but it
ultimately comes back to the insulin
because the cortisol
is raising the insulin it's not the
cortisol directly it's it's an indirect
effect
now let's flip over to the inhibitor
side okay there's several things that
can inhibit insulin and make insulin
more sensitive and less resistant that
would be potassium
vitamin b1
and vitamin d okay all three of those
can greatly help you lower
this insulin resistance situation now
another thing that can make insulin more
sensitive is apple cider vinegar okay
take a tablespoon put some water drink
that that will really help your blood
sugars and then when you actually end up
getting into fat burning
that's called ketosis and ketosis by
itself can increase insulin sensitivity
and then there's three last things that
you have to be aware of if you want to
keep insulin lower because these three
things will trigger
insulin number one inflammation okay
inflammation that comes from omega-6
fatty acids like the so-called vegetable
oils the corn oil the soy oil the canola
those are very inflammatory then you
also have
belly fat in general visceral fat
actually increases inflammation and that
alone could actually increase insulin
msg monosodium glutamate has the
potential to increase insulin it's in a
lot of foods especially in restaurant
foods
and
a lack of sleep can also mess up your
blood sugars and increase insulin this
is why people lose more weight if they
have a good night rest all right now you
have the secret
to bust through
this plateau
and overcome
what you thought was a metabolism
problem in reality it was really an
insulin
problem and on that note if you want
more information about insulin
resistance i put up this video right
here check it out
you